all white people are racist every single
last one of them all of them are racist
and I don't mean that to say like every
single individual white person if I talk
to you you would have some kind of
racist ideology I'm saying that as a
white person you uphold a system of
racism by literally just being white I
believe if you're not spending your
literal entire life dismantling racism
then you're contributing to its
continuation and people get so much
literal entire life not figurative
entire life so if you don't spend every
single moment of your whole life if you
ever sleep
if you ever blink and are not in that
moment fighting racism you're a terrible
racist by virtue of being a white person
which brings you back to the first point
you made which is all white people all
the time are evil terrible racist